the Oscar Pistorius trial had all the
ingredients to make it compulsive
viewing for some it had a good-looking
successful athlete at the height of his
career and his good looking model
girlfriend who her friend said was on
the brink of fame and fortune herself
was it a tragic love story which just
went horribly wrong because of a an
awful accident or was it the result of a
jealous mad violent rage which ended up
in the death of reeva Steenkamp but it
also raised a whole vast multitude of
issues not least this one the whole
issue of guns in South Africa look at
this footage it was footage that Sky
News uncovered and then was used during
the trial it shows Oscar Pistorius and
illustrated not only his obsession with
guns but also highlighted how the whole
of South Africa had a very almost loose
attitude towards weapons we heard during
the course of the trial how Oscar
Pistorius was holding a gun which went
off in the middle of a crowded
restaurant and despite 200 more than 200
people there no one even called the
police it was considered almost normal
that was one of the main issues which
was brought up second issue was all
about reeva Steenkamp
was she a woman who was being abused by
a controlling jealous boyfriend
certainly groups of ANC women's league
supporters came out every day of the
trial to lend support to reeva Steenkamp
smothered June but it was that was all
always a bone of contention during the
trial whether she was being mentally
physically abused by controling
boyfriend or not certainly Oscar
Pistorius and his defense team insisted
they were in a very loving relationship
but the trial was used by some to
highlight and focus in on how in south
freaka many many women are not only
abused but but also suffer silently with
violent domestic abuse another issue was
the whole issue of the the trial itself
and the televising of the trial this was
the first time in South African history
that a criminal trial was broadcast live
an entire channel was devoted to
covering the trial it raised lots of
issues about witness anonymity about
whether people would comes forward it
also showed millions not only those in
South Africa but around the world
South African justice in action and many
people followed it devotedly day-in
day-out on not only on television but
also in social media what will happen
now will this lead to more broadcasting
not only in South Africa but around the
world or will it put people off will it
scare witnesses it also raised the whole
issue of people who have disabilities
one of the central points of Oscar
pistorius's defence was whether his
disability led to him reacting in a way
that was out of kilter to any other
person who had been born and lived with
both their legs was he especially
vulnerable did he react in such a
startled primal way that he had no
control over his reactions when he went
towards the noise that he said he heard
when he his defense was that he was
trying to look after both himself and
his girlfriend so this whole trial was
much more than just about a shooting and
the death of reeva Steenkamp